foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Tuesday
taco Tuesday
Texas fall Tuesday Texas ball is going
to join us today
Midas Mighty favorite
[Music]
we're gonna talk about elections we're
going to talk about Republicans trying
to rig elections that's what we're going
to talk about today not just in Texas
but all around the country and they're
trying to rig them up everywhere to be
quite honest with you they are terrified
of you they are absolutely terrified of
you that you are gonna go out there
and you are going to engage in your
democracy they're absolutely terrified
of it
and Texas Paul is going to talk about
today the things that they're trying to
do
to stop
you from voting
because they know it's coming
I mean they watched in Kansas
they saw on New York's 19th Alaska
now all the indications are that
registration is up in this country and
it ain't it ain't up because Roe was
overturned
and the rights excited it's up because
row is a return and people do not want
their rights taken away from them
so we're gonna talk today about
elections
we're also going to point you in a
direction where you can go
to make sure that you have a hotline
because every state party has one
to make sure that these folks are kept
in check we we played a
a report from CNN the other day
and it talked about these
these Maya Republicans trying to spy
when they're poll Watchers they're
trying to infiltrate and selection
workers they're trying to infiltrate as
the clerks the actual County officials
the state officials the secretary's of
State
the alarm Bells should be ringing folks
the alarm Bells should be ringing
it's dire
we also have a new video today from the
January 6th select committee about the
proud boys
a more proud boy news Stuart Rhodes
apparently
is again fruitlessly requesting that his
trial be delayed
it is uh and he's just filing this
motion he's playing he's playing Trump
here but he's not doing a very good job
the reason why is because Stuart Rhodes
isn't Trump he thinks he is maybe but
he's not
and Stuart Rhodes again files a motion
to ex to delay his trial which is set
for I believe the 27th of the 29th the
actual number escapes me I believe it's
the 29th maybe the 27th I believe that's
a a Monday or Tuesday
one of those days the end of this month
the very last week of this month Stuart
Rhodes and the proud boys will start
their trial one of them
and the January 6 select committee drops
a video today
about the proud boys what they knew
so The Oath Keepers and the proud boys
coordinating
excuse me
but in the video you will see Stuart
Rhodes the founder of The Oath Keepers
and Enrique tario the founder of The
Proud boys I'm Miss speaking I think
Cowboys oathkeepers aren't they the same
[ __ ] thing at this point
I mean when they came together on
January 6 and met in the garage in
Enrique tario and Stewart Rhodes were
making out in the garage
then they just become one organization
at that point
they actually show the footage a little
bit of the footage from the garage where
Stuart Rhodes and Enrique atario
we're playing footsie with each other in
the parking garage on January 5th
planning their attack on the capitol
planning the coup attempt for the Cheeto
dust mobster speaking of Cheeto dust
mobster we found out why
we found out why Grandpa poopy pants
went to DC yesterday
he had to go um scope out a new burial
plot for the next casket that he's going
to fill up with documents and put in the
ground apparently
I don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
he's doing
I would imagine he's doing all sorts of
things he's making it appear as if
he's doing something and he's doing
something different
it's what it always is
he was with Eric Trump which makes me
even more suspicious
I believe I believe they're trying to
get their story straight for the grand
jury that's right there's a grand jury
apparently 40.
40 Trump allies
have either been subpoenaed or had their
devices
seized oh [ __ ]
of those uh seized is Stephen Miller
nothing warms my heart more
than knowing that the FBI had Stephen
Miller's phone
what kind of you think he's got a lot of
vampire bat porn on that phone I don't
know I mean it is Stephen Miller
you would think I mean the guy hangs
upside down at night to sleep doesn't he
from his cave
Stephen Miller's phone is in the hands
of the FBI and also Boris Epstein I
don't know if you know who Boris Epstein
is he was much more prominent during the
2016 campaign
he was he was all over the [ __ ] news
during the 2016 campaign Trump this
Trump that I'd like love to suck Trump's
ass all over and over and over
everywhere the guy wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up
and then when Trump became president he
went to Sinclair broadcasting
you're not familiar with Sin Claire
broadcasting there are a huge right-wing
Media Group in this country that bought
up all kinds of radio stations and local
TV stations and what they would do is
they would have Boris Johnson or excuse
Boris Epstein not Johnson Jesus Christ
my mind is foggy this morning
I guess I had one less cup of coffee
than I needed
Boris Epstein went on Sinclair
broadcasting you have a segment
and these local news stations were
required to play his Trump propaganda
statements I'm not [ __ ] you
this is real
Boris Johnson would do a trump
propaganda segment for local news lies
all of it [ __ ] lies
and they would require these local TV
stations that they bought and purchased
to play
these Nazi propaganda excuse me Trump
propaganda statements from Boris Epstein
and and they stopped Boris they stopped
because even trying to force it down
people's throats people were calling
into these news stations like get this
[ __ ] off of here we don't want this
garbage on here
and eventually they just it Boris you
know faded off into the distance with
this propaganda segments
they wouldn't do them anymore because no
one people were turning off the [ __ ]
TV during the news he would do this
during local news time Prime Time news
six o'clock 10 o'clock news
they would play these [ __ ] Nazi
proper excuse me Trump propaganda
statements from Boris Epstein
it was these why why lying segments is
what they were now Boris Epstein has his
phone seized because apparently
he was part of this fake collector
scheme he was part of the stop the steal
he was part of the save America he was
part of the legal the fraudulent legal
defense fund
folks this is getting really heated very
fast when 40 [ __ ] when 40
[ __ ] after Patrick Maloney has
went and sat before grand jury in DC
over the January 6th
when 40 [ __ ] that are close to
Trump
have their phone seized or subpoenaed to
become before the grand jury a criminal
probe
somebody's [ __ ]
somebody I mean they're they they don't
convene a grand jury like this and
subpoena this many people without
someone getting criminally charged
no [ __ ] way it's the feds
no [ __ ] way
they already have the [ __ ] evidence
they're presenting the evidence to the
grand jury
and they're letting people get get the
opportunity to cooperate here
not a not a good look
for Trump and his close allies who are
trying to steal his supporters money
can you imagine can you imagine how
[ __ ] weird it's gonna be
if Trump is charged
Trump and his team are charged
with stealing fraudulently stealing
his supporters money
while he's using the money that he's
stealing from his supporters to pay for
his defense for that criminal case and
his supporters being happy to give are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me is this [ __ ]
real life
this is real this is it's [ __ ] real
like you can't even make this [ __ ] up
literally what is going to happen
Trump is charged with the fraudulent
legal defense fund for the stop to steal
and save America [ __ ] where he
[ __ ] lost and he won't admit he lost
he is he is going to be charged with
stealing these people's money
defrauding them
just like Bannon was charged in New York
to defraud the people
with we will but we build a wall scam
can you even [ __ ] fathom
the storyline here
Donald Trump and his allies indicted
today on charges of defrauding his
supporters out of money for illegal
events fund which now he's using money
from his supporters that he still
getting to pay for his legal defense
my God
people have lost their way in this
country they've lost their way and
really honestly
um we can't worry too much about the
people who are lost we have to watch
them you got to watch these
[ __ ] they're doing all sorts of
crazy ass [ __ ] we're going to talk about
it today with Texas Paul
we're gonna talk about some of the crazy
[ __ ] out there that are trying
to take over our elections you cannot
look away at that you have to pay
attention to what the [ __ ] these people
are planning
that's the only way to hit this this
stealing these elections
that's the only way to head it off is to
make these elections free fair and
pro-democracy
not some kind of [ __ ] rigged up
[ __ ] like Russia has
it is very important that we stay aware
of what they're doing
but we can't spend our energy
trying to get them to come back over
right I mean Joe Biden's doing a fairly
good job at that by by
calling them semi-fascists they're not
semi-fascists they're full on fascists
you know he's kind of giving him an off
ramp there you know people who are still
maybe Associated or think they like
manga I think Trump's is still a good
idea he's kind of giving him an off rant
there right now [ __ ] that [ __ ]
just Barrel straight into it to hell
with it let's lean into democracy [ __ ]
these people
if they don't want democracy if they
want autocracy and and they and they
hate equity and equality well guess what
we should be intolerant of intolerance
no question full stop we should be
intolerant of intolerance it's enough of
this [ __ ]
it's enough of it let's just lean into
democracy and Barrel forward [ __ ] them
but we have to pay attention to what the
scumbags are doing
you gotta you gotta watch them you can't
ignore them
you gotta watch them
but you don't have to you know they're a
lost cause [ __ ] them it there's enough
of us to create a democracy to create a
society
that eventually they'll want to live in
and if they don't well they'll go crawl
back underneath their [ __ ] rock
[ __ ] them
but it's all coming the walls are
closing in here
I mean I I believe the the meeting on
the golf course yesterday had a lot of
different things they weren't golfing
there were no golf clubs they had some
markers so I don't know if they were
marking where they're going to put a new
sand trap or where they were going to
bury the next casket again with with
documents in it I don't know
but he met with Eric and I apparently
there was a couple Attorneys at some
point on this golf course
which only tells you that it's probably
it's probably a meeting to uh button up
the story that they're going to tell the
grand jury because I think that's
actually the big news yesterday that it
that that no one's really talking about
this morning
that's the big news when you take
Stephen Miller and Boris Epstein's phone
when they take seize their phone after
they seize Eastman
after They seized Clark they arrested
Steve Bannon in New York look if you
don't think that the New York case
against Bannon
for we build a wall has nothing to do
with this other stuff you are out of
your mind
these people are always criming
these people are continuing to crime
they will not stop and it's all all
interconnected it's a it's a [ __ ]
syndicate
so now is the time for you
to put an end to this and lean into
democracy because we had Sherry Jacobus
on yesterday and she laid out what we've
been saying for months and months and
months because I've been listening to
Steve Bannon and Matt Getz
Marjorie Taylor green
some of these other Kooks that want to
make Trump the Speaker of the House
they're they're wanting they'll give him
any power that they can possibly give
them at any turn
and she laid it out yesterday just like
we've laid it out in the past
that they're not gonna just go without a
fight they're gonna go kicking and
screaming
and yeah we're gonna have to hang on to
the guard rails of democracy the whole
[ __ ] way
because they know they know that
democracy
that the main Bedrock is Law and Order
is their worst enemy
they know that
they know they committed crime they know
they stall this these people's money
their supporters money
they know they tried to overthrow an
election they know they tried to
fraudulently submit fake electors that
weren't certified they knew all this
they knew it was [ __ ] illegal hell
Rusty Bowers told you that Rusty Bowers
told you that at the January 6th select
hearing
where he appeared and said yeah they
were trying to [ __ ] sell me [ __ ]
they were trying to get me to go along
with the fraud of the state electors
when you have Congress people members of
congress's phones getting seized
White House advisors phones getting
seized campaign lawyers phones getting
seized when Christina Bob who is
standing in the [ __ ] war room with
Rudy Giuliani and John Eastman and Steve
Bannon
during the January 6 violent
Insurrection where they tried to steal
our democracy away from us
has to get a [ __ ] lawyer
they're in they're in hot trouble and
they did some crazy ass [ __ ] and they
know they did some crazy ass [ __ ] why do
you think he took all them [ __ ]
documents if you really believe that the
documents is a totally separate issue
then then January 6 and this guy
continuing to grift his supporters
you're [ __ ] out of your mind
those documents had everything to do
with Trump and Trump committing crime
100 [ __ ] percent you can't convince
me otherwise even Sean Hannity last
night there's a video of Sean Hannity
he's like look how many investigations
earned Trump and he rolls this scroll
like he's listing out the crimes that
Trump's committed like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
oh they just they're really self unaware
these fascists are at our front door
so it's up to you it's up to you and
we're gonna talk about this today
because I'm telling you Texas Paul is on
to something here he's been telling me
all morning look they're they're helping
they're hell-bent on stealing these
goddamn elections it's not just the
story in Michigan where they're trying
to spy
on Election officials
they're infiltrating the election
offices their infiltrate they're trying
infiltrate the Secretary of State's
positions
there's even some groups
that are affiliated
with terrorists who bomb the Oklahoma
City Building
they're at our front door folks and they
want to take away your democracy and the
reason why is because they don't want
equality and equity
to the to the oppressor equality feels
like oppression
but the freedom
to take away the rights of other people
is not
Liberty
and that is what we strive for in this
country is Liberty 100 percent full stop
and we we shall not quit
I'm not fearful I mean you know maybe
maybe we should fear if these people
actually gain control but I have full
confidence in you folks out there
that you are going to do what it takes
that you are seeing
what they want to do the blueprint that
Ron DeSantis and Greg Abbott
and these other fascists around the
country are trying to lay out
and more and more of their crimes coming
to light
and I think the grand jury in Washington
DC seizing phones and subpoenaing giving
subpoenas issuing subpoenas for the
crimes of the January 6th and the lead
up and the fundraising and the the big
fraud is what it is not a big lie we are
well we are well beyond
a liar a grift we are at the big fraud
folks it is the big fraud we got Texas
Paul here today
stick around we got Texas Paul I also
want to mention if you guys haven't
noticed we have the dark Brandon merch
an exclusive design store.the
tonymichaels.com go there you can get
your dark Brandon t-shirts hoodies
cups
stickers go get you some dark Brandon
merch don't forget now that at store
dot the Tony Michaels .com
you know this dark Brandon thing because
I before I could bring Texas fall on I
want to talk inflation for just a second
this morning the news is oh inflation is
Cooling
Oh you mean you mean dark Brandon did
his job you mean you mean Democrats you
mean Democrats past the biggest
infrastructure bill they passed the
coronavirus for elite package last year
to give Americans a leg up Americans
took the leg up he trusted the American
people he trusted the American working
class
they passed the pack act and they passed
inflation reduction Act
and you're telling me inflation's
cooling well son of a [ __ ]
after Putin
invaded a sovereign country that
murderous [ __ ] dictator which they
they oh the fascists love him that's
what they would like to do here
after he invaded and crude oil prices
skyrocketed because the entire world cut
off Russian oil
Joe Biden and the other world leaders
sprung in action and gasoline is on its
way back down folks it's on its way back
down I don't know if you noticed
they're scraping the Joe Biden I did
that stickers off that gas pumps
because it's going in the wrong
direction so dark Brandon this morning
with the with the news that inflation is
Cooling
even Fox News had it yesterday Neil
Cavuto did a a segment on Fox news about
how inflation is Cooling
that's right even Fox News has to talk
about it they can't avoid it
so go get your dark Brandon merch
because dark Brandon's out there baby
and he's working for the American
working class
that's what he's working for the
American people not for corporations not
for big donors not for a party
the guy is actually getting it done
you know I don't know I you know I I'm
not a huge
sycophant
for dark Brandon and Joe Biden
and I don't know what history will say
about his presidency
but when history compares
Joe Biden's
presidency
to Donald Trump's wholly actual [ __ ]
history is going to tell a great story
of Jill Biden
and his alter ego dark Brandon don't
forget to go to store.dtonymichaels.com
get your dark Brandon merch show your
support
for the alter ego bringing bringing
economic stability and and just plain
old normalcy back to the United States
of America folks stick around when we
come back we have Texas Paul the Midas
Mighty favor we're going to talk
elections we're going to talk polls and
how these Republicans are trying to
steal it don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to this
Chicken around to the break you know
that commercial that gave it there
the Trump fund
that was that was
that was long before we knew wow I mean
we knew it's a scam everything he does
as a scam everything Donald Trump does
is a [ __ ] scam no no question full
stop but that was well before
well before
we understood the gravity of what
happened
after the 2020 election and how he stole
his supporters money and this is going
to be really weird oh this is going to
be strange
but I think we'll make it through I've
got a great guest you know it's Tuesday
and you know what happens here on the
Tony Michaels podcast on Tuesday we have
the mightiest Mighty favorite Texas Paul
Texas Paul how are you
man I started out my morning just
wonderful you know pumpkin spice is back
man and that is my time of year I love
pumpkin spice but by the time I got done
prepping for the show and reading up on
everything that was going on and finding
out how wide this web I mean the
original subject we talked about was bad
but the more I dug into by the time I
got done I was more pissed off than a
badger with hemorrhoids man I tell you
I mean this [ __ ] is bad man I mean hey
hey Paul your your microphone's down do
you get can you turn your mic up
yeah
how's that turn it turn it up just a bit
more
how's that keep going better keep going
hold on
they're saying your volume's too low
in the chat there
how about now
let's see if I can grab it here
now now speak
now
how's that folks is it still yeah I I I
think I've got you I don't know what's
going on over there
I don't know I don't know I got it
cranked up all the way
can you hear me okay
let's make volume great again is what
they're saying I I don't know Gabe can
you can you hear Texas Paul here can you
hear Texas ball here
go ahead Texas
yeah Gabe's saying no no why don't you
do this why don't you why don't you do
this why don't you go out and then come
back in and see if uh the mic will reset
is that fair enough I want people to
hear what you got to say we're good
well hey Gabe good morning good morning
Texas football is having a few um a few
issues difficulties yeah well it happens
Texas Paul if you want to go out of the
uh out of the room and there he is maybe
that'll maybe that'll work let's see if
we can get it how about now how about
now my friends
welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast
let's see if I can uh automatically
adjust here we go okay I think we're
good now
I had to laugh my wife came sliding in
the room she's like he really is bad man
you can't hear
you hear that Mrs Texas Paul
is a is an average and she watches the
Tony Michaels buckets especially when
Texas ball is on here of course
oh she does she loves your show man she
really does I uh I've been you know like
I said I had covered and after I had
covet I've had vertigo
and I had a really bad case this morning
and she told me you better get your [ __ ]
wired straight buddy because you're
doing that show today
what we're going to talk about today
because you you were messaging me about
what you wanted to talk about today and
it's this um it's these groups all
around the country we we Gabe went over
a video and I actually think you did a
review of it on the Midas Dutch networks
channel of a report about these Michigan
folks uh the the one of the County
Chairs doing Zoom meetings to try to
train people on how to be spies
yeah yeah it it is something else man it
is really something else the uh
uh uh
sorry about that I'm having a little bit
of a technical difficulty
um the
damn it
sorry about that no no we wait yeah this
is this is live this is what happens
when you have livedex as well sorry
about that folks
um I just did the uh uh a whole video on
it there there up in Michigan they were
running training programs you know poll
Watchers are supposed to be
nonpartisan they're supposed to just do
their job you know I mean it's not
supposed to be one way or the other but
you've got these folks up in Michigan
that are just
out of their minds up in you know up
around Detroit and and the county around
there they're hiring partisan groups
that are telling poll Watchers that they
had that they have to
uh carry in notebooks which is illegal
okay to smuggle in cell phones which is
illegal and you know how these Cairns
you know it doesn't have to be a crime
for them to go off I mean you remember
what
they did to to uh you know Miss miles
there when she was
her mama just passed her a ginger mint
and they had this whole conspiracy
theory that it was a a
USB drive a thumb drive
and it was just a damn mint and they
tear around there you these are the
people they're hiring to be poll
Watchers
and their training actually break the
law they're telling them well the law is
just unjust because you know Republicans
never feel like the law applies to them
right and right well I mean I mean
Chinese people to break no that's that's
their MO Texas Paul right now is that
Law and Order only applies to the people
that they say it applies to and they are
definitely do not uh have to adhere to
the law and order that is for sure I
mean we're seeing time again
and the worst part about it is they're
not telling them to do what you're
supposed to do which is if you see
something wrong a poll Watcher's
supposed to call the county clerk right
that's what they're supposed to do
they're given a number they're trained
so that the clerk can immediately
dispatch somebody and take care of the
problem they're telling their people to
call 9-1-1
Chiefs are essentially trying to swat
voters is what they're trying to do it's
an intimidation tactic and we'll talk
more about that later because that's
part of what we're we're going to talk
about today
why I'm glad you you kind of got
straight into it about this intimidation
tactic because there's a few things I I
want to to go over today but I know I
know you kind of have this topic about
uh poll intimidation and why why we need
to stay vigilant
um because again you know we I we talk
about here on the show on the Tony
Michaels podcast about engaging in your
democracy and leaning into it and that
has to do with not just marking your
ballot but make sure that son of a [ __ ]
is valid make sure your registration is
there make sure that these son of a
[ __ ] aren't trying to steal away your
elections by by doing tactics like the
spying like bringing in cell phones like
calling 9-1-1 instead of you know
actually using the legal protocol and we
have several people
um at our disposal to do this and I know
you want to share a few things today
about how we can stay vigilant here but
give us a rundown of what some of these
groups are and and where they're going
with this
but you've got a one group in particular
it's a constitutional sheriffs and Peace
Officers Association
uh they're headed back by the name of
Sheriff Richard Mack
and he's got a long history going all
the way back to the 80s he actually sued
uh to he was the guy that was part of
the Sovereign citizen movement and sued
and made his way all the way to the
Supreme Court and actually won his case
um
what he did was he said Sheriff
shouldn't enforce
background checks that was the way the
Brady Bill was written was that the
sheriff's local sheriffs would do the
background checks because if somebody is
illegally buying a firearm well the
sheriff would have it in hand right then
and there you could take care of it
legally
right this guy said no he's a second
amendment freak he doesn't like
background checks at all I said you
can't force me to do that and he got all
the way to the Supreme Court Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court said well
yeah the federal government can't make
you do that which just fed into the
whole Sovereign citizen thing and while
this case was going on a lot of people
don't realize that you know Timothy
McVeigh the Oklahoma City bomber and
Terry Nichols were both
supercharged by this guy
I mean he was a hero in The Sovereign
citizen movement and he was actually
what inspired Timothy McVeigh to bomb
the Oklahoma City bomb the Oklahoma City
Building
we know that because they talked to
Timothy McVeigh they they convicted him
and they before you know they got done
with him they they knew exactly what
inspired him and it was Richard Mackin
this whole Sovereign citizen movement
you know these these delusional nut
balls which are no different than the
kyogenon freaks today
believe
that the Federal Government is out to
get them
well you know Sovereign
citizens are kind of the pre-q Anon
right I don't know if you've ever met
like personally or have one in your
family or you sat down and listened to
them talk about this [ __ ] but I mean it
doesn't take more than two or three
minutes and you're like what in the
actual [ __ ] are you talking about I mean
they think they can relinquish their
citizenship and now they're now now they
have autonomy from all laws and taxes
all kinds of craziness they talk about
maritime law they just say absolutely
crazy oh yes batshit stuff but to your
point Paul it's to convince the crazies
that the government is this big bad
monster that's out to get them and
that's how they create this idea of this
stochastic terrorism that we're seeing
more and more now where
um the former president is posting Q
Anon [ __ ] post on fraud social we
have more and more people will going to
play footsie with Q Anon again where we
we weren't seeing that up until a month
or so ago where Q wasn't doing any drops
we actually had Jim Stewardson on
where he talks about Q Anon he's got a
great documentary on Q Anon and how
they're mining [ __ ] America because I
think that's what you're saying here is
that is that Timothy McMay was kind of
mind [ __ ] by this other this this
Sheriff who is trying to get these ideas
in people's heads you know a wink wink
and a nod not type thing
yeah Timothy McVeigh was was part of the
uh The Wolverine Watchman in Michigan
and he was absolutely inspired by all of
this I mean 100 I mean we know for that
for a fact
but these crazies didn't go away the
Wolverine Watchman by the way are the
same people same group just arrested if
you remember uh you know about a year
and a half ago uh for
conspiring to kidnap the governor of
Michigan Gretchen Whitmer this is the
same group they didn't go away
yeah I mean they all all of these groups
every one of them have these ideologies
of you know like small government or
we're going to overthrow militia you
know whatever they're going to be
there definitely is a trend when they go
to either
a tiki torch rally right or they go to
you know uh protest this or protest that
or whatever they they tend to have a a
pattern of rebranding themselves they
never go away fully right the only way
that these people go away is if they're
actually like you know put in jail or
imprisoned or something worse happens to
them by accident
but what I will say is that there is a
trend for sure of all these groups as
they try and when they get called out or
they get defeated in whatever their plan
is then they say okay we're gonna we're
gonna go back into our shell and then
we've rebranded something else as if no
one else had any idea who they were
right they think that everyone's stupid
like you've got Vanguard who's like okay
fine we'll leave Charlottesville and
then we Rebrand and we become Patriot
front as if nobody has the accessibility
of the internet or has any research
skills to look up and say oh these are
the same guys there's different colors
in a different logo right
um but all of them have the same
tendency where they'll just recoil
Rebrand thinking that they'll be
reinvented and no one will know who they
are
but that's not how it goes right well
and I mean we see that we see the exact
same thing with these election groups
right I mean because isn't there one I
think you just uh messaged me here
there's one um cspoa POA
um and that group is actually affiliated
with uh Stuart Rhodes and The Oath
Keepers which there's big proud boy and
oathkeeper news today see what Rhodes is
again trying to get them to delay the
trial they're Pro they're probably not
going to do that but um the January 6th
select committee actually released a
video and I want to watch that with you
Paul but tell me about the C cspoas tell
me about this group and how they are
affiliated with The Oath Keepers
it's exactly what game shots the game
just said I mean it is you're not going
to believe this when I tell you you're
not you're just it's amazing
the cspoa is run by Richard Mack like I
said that's why I was talking about
giving you that background about the
Brady Bill and who this guy is okay he
was a sheriff in Arizona
and he starts this group the
Constitutional Sheriff's and Peace
Officers Association he is best buddies
with
Elmer Rhodes Stuart roach who's now
under indictment uh facing trial you're
talking about for January 6th of
freaking terrorists yeah I believe it's
September 29th it's 27th or 29th is when
it begins and he's trying to delay it
that's the motion that he's filing again
today which he filed last week and lost
sorry I didn't mean to step by yeah go
ahead The Oath Keepers well this you
know these groups are founded in racism
this is not this is not you know some
group but it's the same messaging the
same mission is they want to talk about
the border and you know you fast forward
to today I mean Richard Mack was on the
board of The Oath Keepers that's how
close these guys are
um
Richard Mack is down in Kenny County
Texas working with the sheriff Co down
there to try to get Greg Abbott and you
know to Greg Abbott here in Texas has
been on this huge anti-immigration kick
it's he thinks that's going to keep him
in office because nobody that that
doesn't live at the border actually
knows about the border so they believe
all this [ __ ] and you've got Mac
working with with Sheriff Co down in
Kenny County to try to get Abbott which
he goes along with he's tied with them I
mean they're they're this close folks I
mean they're this close
um
to try to declare we're under Invasion
on our Southern border right literally
under Invasion and he's tied in with
Texas politics now and Abbott loves him
so much that there's another group
called Tico this is a legitimate
organization that that's the Texas
commission on law enforcement
they are the regulatory agency within
the state that regulates law enforcement
you have to be a licensed
you have to have a license in the state
of Texas to be in law enforcement
Tico
the Texas commission on law enforcement
has made the cspoa an official trainer
to certify law enforcement in this state
I mean that's how much Abbott loves
these people because they are pushing
his anti-immigration message well he
loves them so much he's now
putting them in our elections
they are literally pushing the cspoa is
on a huge push they've all all been part
of this anti you know the big lie Trump
was never defeated that that that's who
these people are
um
they have been pushing this like crazy
and Greg Abbott has them involved in our
elections now they're going to police
our elections
well you know that well I I want to
bring up something here because
um it seems like you're saying that the
the police are being trained to quote
unquote police the elections but here's
the deal is you just said a while ago
that when these election launchers are
supposed to actually
um
call the county clerk of the election
official they're calling 9-1-1
I don't think that's by accident that
they're training police to be called
when these election washers call for
whatever it is spying or whatever the
hell they're doing that they're calling
law enforcement because maybe they just
figure well we're going to have the best
chance at getting an officer here who's
going to do whatever we want and do what
we want at these polls I mean do you
think that has something to do with it
it's why they're telling people to call
9-1-1 and get a law enforcement officer
there and sheriffs there do you think
that could have something to do with it
absolutely absolutely that is why and it
does go back to Michigan in this group
there's a Sheriff up there named Dar
Leaf who has been in locked in a mortal
battle with the Michigan attorney
general and when I say Mortal I mean his
ass is on the line because Sheriff Dar
leaf
who is part of the seat you know is a
cspo a darling they have him on all the
time they love this guy is going after
uh or pardon me is a target of the
investigation from Dana nessel the
Attorney General
in Michigan for tampering with voting
machines he used his authority to take
voting machines
and they know they broke into them
so Nestle and and her opponent her
Republican opponent is a guy by the name
of Matt deperno
um
she's asked for a special counsel to be
appointed because she's running against
a guy that's a target of this
investigation Matt deperno and Matt
diperno and darleeve are the two people
that were spearheading this
I mean you talk about the same people
that are
trying to not trying to are
being pushed by the cspoa to be
monitoring our elections are absolutely
the same people that are targets of
Investigation we're fearing in our
elections well be and that's the more of
this this Maga Republican this these
fascist projecting their crime onto
other people and that's exactly what
we're doing and this seems to be a
pattern because you have Tina Peters you
have Tina Peters in in Colorado uh Texas
Paul is having a little trouble with
this his video but not I think his audio
is fine but we we see this with uh Tina
Peters in Colorado and then we also see
this same thing uh down in Georgia and
Coffee County we lost Texas Paul but
Gabe we see this down in Coffee County
in in Georgia where they let these
election yeah literally have video
footage of them being allowed into
tamper with these voting machines right
and you made a good point earlier about
about uh
about the police right you you and Texas
ball bring up something interesting
which is like yes you know the idea that
this is intentional right you want them
like one not only is this a wasted uh
resource right we are now funding police
to go to election uh polling places
instead of actually doing their job
which is to Serve and Protect the
community Okay so
that's the one big thing is obviously
wasting resources and say well you know
and not only that but you know
attempting to argue for Budget uh kind
of adjustments and say well we need more
money because we've been called out this
many times because I believe there is
something around like uh you know how
many times been called out you know what
the resources are used so that you can
justify next year's budget for that
department of its uh you know uh the
fire department of police department
what have you but if you call out these
people to say oh wait there's a crime
being committed I as a citizen want to
uh alert you the official law
enforcement of this crime which is
somebody is is committing voter fraud
but these people don't know that not
only that but you're taking away this is
voter intimidation you're taking away
people's right to vote you're removing
that ability and then let's say later on
someone goes oh yeah this was total
[ __ ]
it's too late you you lost your right to
vote because they pulled you out for how
many of our hours or whatever it might
be because somebody says I don't like
this person they clearly are liberal or
democrat or a leftist or whatever it
might be and they want to use that a
militarized state which is what they're
they're advocating for right they're at
they're asking for a militia to regulate
you know uh the polling place which
makes it a very dangerous and
intimidating way because it's like you
walk there you take time out of your day
because you know election day is not a
holiday so you're taking time out of
your day uh your commute your travel to
work before or after to say okay I'm
gonna go vote
but then even then it's a big question
mark of whether you'll be even allowed
to vote because if someone's already
like prejudiced against you because you
look a certain way you said something
wrong you give off a certain Vibe or
whatever as opposed to everyone has the
fair and you know the the right to
exercise a fair and free election
but it's the militarized uh movement of
local law enforcement to justify their
own kind of authoritarian uh budget
increases you know requirements
resources exactly it is you know and but
again but that's why they but that's why
they say this kind of stuff right and it
comes back to this projection of hey
we want this thing we want authoritarian
rule we want this power we want to have
actually a militarized state we want to
make sure that nobody has accessibility
or their rights or you know the the
ability to vote for the candidate that
will represent them and support
democracy so it's that whole thing of
like you know we saw Glenn Greenwald
last night on Tucker Carlson uh talking
about this and it's it is just that
projection from the right to say we
actually want to have those things that
we put on the Democrats to have well
I've got a video here from January 6. I
don't know if you guys have watched this
yet they put out another video they're
dropping we are going to have hearings
in the next few weeks the next one is
announced for the 28th
um there may be one before there may be
one after they're waiting I think
they're waiting on to see if there's
going to be a surprise
um appearance by a person who was
supposed to be hung on uh on January 6
but this this but this shows how even
they're willing to go to authoritarian
links after they've lost elections to
violently stop the certification of
Elections here is here's the January 6
uh newest video that they put out let's
give it let's give it a quick watch here
and then we'll talk about it on the
other side if I can get my controls to
work here my name is Marcus Childress
and I'm an investigative Council for the
select committee to investigate the
January 6 attack on the United States
capital what do you want to call them
give me a name give me a white
supremacies
stand back and stand by after he made
this comment Enrique tario then chairman
of The Proud boys said on parlor
standing by Sir during our investigation
we learned that this comment during the
presidential debate actually led to an
increase in membership from the proud
boys would you say that proud boys
numbers increased after the stand back
standby comment exponentially I'd say
tripled probably with the potential for
a lot more eventually and did you ever
sell any stand back and stand by
merchandise
uh one of the vendors on my page
actually beat me to it but I wish I
would have I wish I would have made a
stand back standby shirt on December
19th president Trump tweeted about the
January 6 rally and told attendees be
there will be wild
many of the witnesses that we
interviewed were inspired by the
president's call and came to D.C for
January 6. but the extremists they took
it a step further they viewed this tweet
as a call to Arms a day later the
Department of Justice describes how the
problem always created a chat called the
ministry of self-defense leadership chat
in this chat the problem was established
a command structure in anticipation of
coming back to DC on January 6. the
Department of Justice describes Mr tario
coming into possession of a document
called the 1776 returns which describes
individuals occupying key buildings
around the United States capital The
Oath Keepers are another group that the
committee investigated you better get
your ass to D.C folks this Saturday
yeah if you don't there's there'll be no
more Republic but we're not going to let
that happen it's not even if it's it's
either president Trump is encouraged and
bolstered and strengthening to do what
he must do or we wind up in a bloody
fight we all know that the fight's
coming The Oath Keepers began planning
to block the peaceful transfer of power
shortly after the November 3rd election
and according to the Department of
Justice Stuart Rhodes The Oath Keepers
leader said to his followers that we
were not going to get through this
without a Civil War in response to the
December 19th 2020 tweet by President
Trump The Oath Keepers focus on January
6 in Washington D.C in response to the
Tweet one member the president of the
Florida Chapter put on social media the
president called us to the Capitol he
wants us to make it wild the goal was
for The Oath Keepers to be called to
duty so that they could keep the
president in power although president
Trump had just lost the election the
committee learned that the Oath Keepers
set up quick reaction forces outside of
the city in Virginia where they stored
arms the goal of these quick reaction
forces was to be on standby by just in
case president Trump invoked the
Insurrection act did Via Keepers ever
provide weapons to members
only inclined to answer that epidemic
Browns for uh and due process grounds in
footage obtained by the committee we
learned that on the night of January 5th
Enrique tarrio and Stuart Rhodes met in
a parking garage in Washington DC
there's mutual respect there
were
we're fighting the same fight and I
think that's what's important
the committee learned that the Oath
Keepers went into the capitol through
the East doors into stack formations the
doj alleges that one of the stacks went
into the capitol looking for speaker
Pelosi although they never found her as
the attack was unfolding Mr tario took
credit and documents obtained by the
Department of Justice Mr tario said in
an encrypted chat made no mistake and we
did this
later on that evening Mr tarrio even
posted a video which seemed to resemble
him in front of the Capitol with a black
cape and the title of the video was
premonition
the evidence developed by the select
committee and the Department of Justice
highlights how each group participated
on the attack on the capitol on January
6. in fact the investigation revealed
that it was individuals associated with
the proud boys who instigated the
initial breach at the peace Circle at 12
53 pm
within 10 minutes rioters had already
filled the Lower West Plaza
foreign
by two o'clock rioters had reached the
doors on the west and the East plazas
and by 213 rioters had actually broken
through the Senate wing door and got
into the Capitol building
a series of breaches followed
at 2 25 PM rioters breached the east
side doors to the Rotunda
[Applause]
and then right after 2 40 PM Riders
breached the east side doors near the
ways and mainstream
once the rioters infiltrated the capital
they moved to the Crypt
the Rotunda
the hallways leading to the house
Chambers
and even inside the Senate chambers
and there you have it the uh the the
latest video put out by the January 6th
select committee
um we know that Stuart Rhodes is trying
to delay his trial again I believe he's
being told to delay his trial and the
reason why is because it's not going to
be pretty to have this trial going on as
people are getting their ballots and
preparing their balance preparing their
way that they're going to be elected
especially Paul if we have the same
groups The Oath Keepers and the brown
boys that are associated with these
election Watchers so the people storming
the capital looking for Nancy Pelosi
with a qrf the stash of weapons across
the Potomac are associated with these
people trying to steal your elections
hmm seems kind of funny doesn't it
can you hear me there Paul
yeah I've got a little bit of a delay I
apologize it's not my internet
connection I don't know what's going on
it's something with stream yard today
it's just insane
um I'm actually running at 50 megabits
per second I'm sorry guys I don't know
what's going on I'm gonna kick out and
come back on after this but uh yeah it's
it's
insane to have these people
involved with our elections and they are
it is what you're not seeing it's the
people that elevated Stewart Rhodes
you've got the Republican Party working
with these people
to try to get them to screw with our
elections period I mean you got the
cspoa telling people to you know law
enforcement that they need to be
you know CH I mean just all over this
like white on rice I mean that that they
need to use every bit of their Authority
and you know down south here we have a
thing
um you know that's very popular it's
souls to the polls well it's popular all
over the country but down south there
it's a big deal right and you've got law
enforcement constantly interfering with
this in Texas they passed laws so that
voting would not overlap with Sunday
uh to to prevent this uh but you've got
cops that will pull these church vans
over they'll drive these church vans all
year and never get pulled over once but
on the way to the elections well we've
got to pull you over because uh you know
we've got a safety issue we've got to
check out or some [ __ ] like that I
mean it's it it's constantly it's it's
like we talked about that project Blitz
where it's just like from all directions
this is what it's like and yet Elmer
Rose does not want this happening during
the election I guarantee you people are
talking to his attorneys and telling
them
shut this down we don't want this in the
next two months this is prime time
right well I mean I I think you're right
that that they don't they do not want
this to be out in the Forefront while
they're having these elections you want
to go out do you want to go out and come
back in Paul and then we'll see if we
can work that through me and Gable talk
yeah you can do something about it okay
yeah
um I was gonna say the the the well the
main reason obviously that you know they
don't want this in close proximity to
these big dates such as the midterm
election is because they don't want the
distraction right so right now they're
trying to distract with again bringing
up Hunter Biden talking about how Joe
Biden is a fascist dictator you know
authoritarian rule uh uh trying to blame
the Democrats for creating a society
that is more violent or hostile because
of Biden's rule
um you know they're trying to push these
things or they're trying to push the
idea that you know the documents the
classified top secret skiff you know
government documents that happen to be
be in uh in Donald Trump's desk in other
parts of the Mar-A-Lago estate and
potentially other properties that he has
they're trying to argue that oh no no
there's nothing wrong this isn't
actually a trump problem it's a storage
problem or it's an overdue library book
or you know he didn't actually have
these documents or you know he
Declassified them or whatever I'd be
like these are all things they cannot
have happen because all of their
narratives before this gas prices
inflation those things are coming down
Ukraine versus Russia we're finding that
Ukraine is actually beating Russia's ass
more than Republicans want to happen
these are all things that are moving
toward they're moving the needle toward
a point to say democracy does work or
actually you know under Democratic
policies and programs we actually can
help the American people we actually can
make America what we actually believe
that it can be in its potential but
Republicans right now are going to
distract with various things they do not
obviously want these things come out
that's what they want to delay they
don't like the fact that the judge just
ordered I think it was October 20
something 24th uh is that they are not
going to allow Trump to delay the Trump
org uh investigation any further because
they called it out they're like look you
guys are delaying this you're talking
about the criminal probe not the Civil
probe right right right and they're like
we know you're delaying this this is a
tactic that you're doing right now so
we're not going to allow it any further
and they're like look the the court date
is now it starts on this day in October
and we're not pushing this [ __ ] anymore
and so that is the thing where it's
across the board and all of these
different things the Republicans
are trying to push past the midterms or
distract by throwing you know nonsense
on on these other actual investigations
or the actual crimes being committed or
have been committed or being looked into
on the Republican party and that again
goes to what we were saying before well
and I think I think these are all good
points push past the election because
they're trying to to distract and here
is
um from the elections that's what some
of this poll watching and stuff is and
calling 9-1-1 instead of calling
election officials because here's my
mark Elias
um on Chris Hayes last night explaining
how they're trying to flood the zone of
[ __ ] to distract from the actual
work of this election that is happening
listen
yeah and this is really really important
Chris because I think in that article it
also talked about that many of these
requests were seeking information from
2020. so it's not like they were seeking
information that would be applicable for
2022. it's simply to divert the
resources of constrained resource
um uh election officials and election
offices so that they can't be doing the
work that they have to be doing
preparing for 2022. the frivolous
challenges that I mentioned these Mass
challenges that they're submitting are
in part an effort to disenfranchise
voters but it takes enormous resources
for election officials to have to look
up these voters see if they are in fact
uh correctly registered if have they
moved have something happen that they're
not registered all of these things are
aimed at preventing election officials
from doing the one thing that they need
to be spending their time doing right
now which is registering voters sending
out absentee ballot applications and
beginning to cite polling locations and
prepare for high turnout elections in
2022. this is not an accident this is
part of the plan
and they're trying to flood the Zone
here um is what they're trying to do so
it's also it's it's no different than
what the Trump Administration did during
their time in office especially with all
the things that were done at the border
how you know children and families were
handled in other states their goal there
being that they can flood the courts
with frivolous cases about things that
are being done so basically instead of
actually going through the you know the
natural order or protocol of law they
say all right we're just going to do
this thing and if Democrats or the
opposition really care about what we did
and that we like broke the law or
whatever they they claim then they can
come after us but there's so many things
that now Democrats and other people in
opposition have to decide what is more
important is it this situation or is it
this other situation and how many funds
and resources do we have available to
actually allocate to fight this court
case to say this is totally inhumane to
treat these people this way or this is
totally unfair to do this basically it's
just like you know a shotgun effect of
uh going for everything and then and you
know it is effective in the sense that
like you now as a team that you know doj
FBI or the Democrats have to decide
which thing is more important to focus
on meanwhile those other things that
Republicans just push through or or blew
up are now years
of damage that has been done collateral
damage and actually ex you know
explicitly to someone or a group of
people where now Democrats have decided
later on like oh [ __ ] can we go back
years and repair this this broken system
or these policies that were that we
didn't have time or the availability to
do in the first place and it's the same
thing here when you see with poll
workers just blasting to be like all
right well if we distract them we cause
enough confusion or enough chaos then we
can either do something to the election
or we can cause uh more votes on our
side by reducing the amount of votes on
the other side well and that's that the
point Texas Paul is to flood the Zone
don't you think just flood the Zone
flood the Zone flood the Zone that's
what Trump does best he's a chaos
machine he's the chaos King
yeah absolutely it's part of what we
talked about last week with project
Blitz it's it's right it's all part of
it it is the these are
you know they're they're going to come
at us from every direction to clog up
the courts to clog up the election you
know I mean they that it's just their
whole Moda simmer apparenti right now
it's it's
their plan and they're telling us their
plan out loud
and you've got Governors all over the
country like Greg Abbott and and
DeSantis DeSantis just did the same
thing he held a press conference about
those guys that uh 20 people that he
supposedly arrested that were committed
voter fraud well we find out that's
[ __ ] they they didn't commit voter
fraud that they were actually we have
six of these guys that have said hey
I confirmed with the state the state
told me I'm allowed to vote
before I filed for before I filed for my
my voter registration I met with the
clerk and I said look well I need to
verify I am legal to vote they checked
with their with their you know probation
officers and and they just they were all
legal to vote as far as they knew
and then DeSantis turns around and holds
this big press conference you know so
that they can turn around and use it to
claim that there's voter fraud going on
so their people will sit back and allow
them to cheat the way they're intending
to cheat the way we're talking about
here today you've got
you know like groups like The cspoa
you've got Greg Abbott bringing these
people in you've got County elections
officials that are absolutely following
a plan it's not a they're all dancing
the same dance that doesn't happen
without a choreographer
one and I'll tell you because I think a
lot of people out there want to know how
how do we stop this and we're not going
to stop them from committing crime right
like that's where I mean at this point
as they're ongoing as they're committing
crime the only thing we can do is to try
to rely on our justice system to do that
the problem is is they've infiltrated a
lot of law enforcement here
um but but the thing that we can do is
we can organize we can get around our
communities because there's plenty of
people in the community that are sick
and tired of this stuff they're tired of
people telling them what they can and
can't do when you can and can't vote
what you can and can't do with your your
your body
um how you can and can't parent who you
can and cannot love and I think that's
where we're getting to where America is
just sick and tired of that [ __ ] and
there are options
um out there this is one of them uh he's
running around the state of Texas
talking in communities and having
Community talk hey Texas farm wonder if
anyone will recognize a guy in this
video
I think it's what you tweeted earlier
but this is I'm telling you folks
democracy is the way out of this this
nonsense it really is the way out that's
why they're fighting so hard against
democracy
is because they know it's their worst
enemy that's why they're doing it so
let's watch this little tape here from
the Beto campaign see if you recognize
someone uh in the in the in through the
video only are we in the fight of our
lives but we are going to fight like
hell we are going to win this election
on the night of November 8th we're going
to do it for each other we're going to
do it for Texas
[Music]
[Applause]
how are we doing
[Applause]
[Music]
we just learned that there are hundreds
of others who are outside who could not
get in today
[Applause]
I want to make sure
that they hear us loud and clear Greg
Abbott has failed the people of Texas
and he's killing the women among us
right now I want you to remember that
but there's an answer to that
for a democrat in Denton County in 2016
was 37 two years later we won 46 percent
my argument to you is if you will sign
up with us today and listen we must win
there he is I ask you to take just one
volunteer shift if we go out and meet
the voters and when we put this before
them as it was put before the voters in
Kansas a referendum on a woman's right
to make her own decisions about her own
body we win this election we restore
those protections we ensure that women
can make their own decisions going
forward are you with me on this
let's do this
so there's a Beto O'Rourke uh in in this
video here uh on on then and this is how
you do it Paul this is how you do it
this is how you lean into democracy this
is how you engage and I I could play the
last minute or so where they're signing
up people uh to do the block walks where
they're rocking around talking to people
because that's what I've been telling
everyone you have to talk to your family
your friends the people in your
neighborhood your colleagues your church
parishioners the people at the PTA damn
the people in the line at the grocery
store because now is the time to save
our democracy not after we can't wait
until Steve band The Steve Bannon types
take over the house we can't wait for
his candidates Tim him and Trump's
candidates to take over the house we
have to do this now now this next few
months is so crucially important that we
engage in our democracy and Beto is
laying out a great great Strat strategy
for any candidate out there to go and
talk about Community now you were at
this event
yeah yeah it was great I'm telling you
folks the the if you've never been to
one of Beto's town halls or it's just
full of energy I mean it is full of
energy everybody there is excited I'm
motivated
um I actually sat right next to a woman
who leaned over after she figured out
who I was and you know I kept taking
pictures with people and people you know
they recognized me right away
um and I you know I probably took 50
pictures that day but it was fun it was
a blast she's she leans over she's like
who are you and I explained and she's
like oh well you're probably not gonna
like this but I'm a republican I'm like
no I love the fact that you're a
republican tell me about it and she has
been a lifelong Republican
and she was there because
Roe v Wade drove her there she's like
this is not my party I am not Maga I am
not these people I am never Trump and
they're just they've this is reeked down
to the state level so badly that
I just can't ignore it and vote
Republican anymore so I want to find out
what's going on and she absolutely loved
beta love better she realized that you
know there aren't really that many
differences between us I mean when you
start talking about the differences
between the Republicans and Democrats in
general
it's when you get into the fine details
that is mostly the difference
um you know it it it's it's it's you
know they always say Devil's in the
details that's where most the difference
is is in the details because if you get
the and I'm not talking about Maga I'm
talking about the Republicans that Joe
Biden identified that worked with him to
get his agenda passed
those are the people
that really don't have that much
difference between us
and and
you know this lady is not a one-off
every one of these rallies you go to
these people are everywhere they're
former Republicans they're people that
and she doesn't know it but she's a
Democrat now
once she casts that ballot she'll be
okay with the title
right you know right now it's because of
the culture wars she's like well I guess
I have to say I'm an independent
and I'm like well you're welcome we've
got a big tent here right right well
because we're the pro-democracy it's the
pro-democracy side right and and I I
hate that we have to say sides but
really we're in a situation where we
don't have two parties you either are
pro-democracy or you're for fascism at
this point because they have drawn the
line the fascists have drawn that Line
in the Sand and Beto is not playing into
that right he's not playing into the
chaos machine and the [ __ ] what I
love best is you called it a rally but
every single one of these videos and
you've been to several of these events
Paul
when I watch these videos they're in
small venues they're not in big huge
Arenas because I mean as many people as
what at this event he could fill and a
big Auditorium he could fill a big venue
but he's not doing that because I think
Beto really at the heart of this and
this is what people are seeing is that
it's about Texas it's about Community
it's about those people not some scary
enemy that doesn't exist it's about you
your government your democracy is about
you tell us Paul all these events you've
been to is that what you're seeing
absolutely at at this particular event
in in Denton where I'm in the video
where you see the side profile of the
you know they got me when I was in was
was was enthralled but when we walked
outside
I didn't get a picture with Matt at this
event
you know normally we we'll we'll shoot
the breeze for about two or three
minutes and I'll get a picture and you
know we'll we'll talk for a minute no
not this time there were literally more
people standing outside
watching on a video screen and listening
to a simulcast then there were people in
the building and we packed that building
to code
they would not the fire marshal would
not allow another soul in that building
they were literally standing room only
all the way to the wall you know
um when we got outside to take pictures
that line was already more than a
football field long
I mean and he stood there and talked
with every one of these people I mean he
must have been there for three or four
hours taking pictures after after two
two about two and a half hours uh Mrs
Texas Paul and I gave up and we said hi
we're going home
well you make it well I was gonna say
you you make a great I mean even with
your story earlier about the woman like
I empathize with her mainly for the
reason of like her not feeling
comfortable with taking that title as
I'm a Democrat now because of the
community obviously you know being in
Texas being like how do the people
around me you know are politically right
I don't want to say Democrat because I
don't want to be stigmatized or I don't
need the black sheep of my family or my
group even though there are certain
things that Republicans have done to
make me uncomfortable with taking that
title as I am a Republican or the label
is I'm a republican but also
is that you know this is a group that
will welcome you right which is the
opposite of what Republicans will do I
mean you look at the rallies even the
Trump the one that Trump had in
Pennsylvania was filled with hate it's
always filled with hate it's filled with
vicious painful type of rhetoric that is
always US versus them and yes as Tony
said it is unfortunate that we are on
this kind of like us versus them which
side are you on but right now the fact
is democracy and our rights are at stake
and if we don't do what we need to do
which is actually go out and vote and
and support people with you know
Democratic liberal values or policies
then we will actually see these things
removed entirely and the people on the
Republican side will then realize
way later oh shoot where did those
rights go that I thought I had and it's
like those things were removed years ago
well yeah well so one more thing I want
to talk about because you're saying the
line is long I want to talk about this
event because I think this these videos
that they're putting out not only are
they Suburban media uh anyone out there
that knows anything about video and
media the Trump or the the Beto campaign
is kicking ass on this right now at the
end when they do the new voter thing how
many times are they bringing that Bell
oh my God I mean you would not believe
the number of there's a look I'm an old
political guy I am I am I'm way back
when Steve Carvel had hair
political guy okay I mean and one rules
one of the rules is never rely on a
youth movement ever
because they get excited but they don't
vote
these people
not only are they excited
not just on social media these people
are showing up for the events these
people are volunteering they're knocking
on doors the reason that Beto's knocked
on so many doors isn't because of my old
ass niece it's these young people they
are and if you've got these people
volunteering believe me they'll take the
day off and go vote this is going to be
a sea change I mean a sea change in in
politics because right now all politics
is geared towards old people because you
know we show up we vote
young people showing up at the polls
will change everything politics will
become more future oriented it will
begin to start looking 10 20 years down
the road instead of just reactionary
like we have now it's wonderful what
Beto's doing here that he is drawing so
many of these young people out and that
damn Bell like you said just I mean over
and over and you've got to give better
this I don't know how his voice holds up
I don't know what he's drinking or
gargling with or what it is but I'm
going to get him to tell me one day
because man every one of these young
people not only did he ring the bell but
he got their name he screamed out their
name and the crowd cheered and clapped
for him uh you know it's amazing I mean
the energy is just amazing at these
rallies
well uh dragon racer brings up something
here rovember is coming and I think
that's why these young folks
that's why they're so engaged is because
they realize that yes what people are
saying is true about Republicans they
want to take your rights away from you
not not they want to stop you from
giving you rights the ones you already
have now in this country the Liberties
that you already possess they want to
take them away from you and it's not
hyperbole it's not like oh well maybe
they did it and they continue to do it
and they're pushing and pushing and
pushing and pushing especially in States
like Texas Florida Georgia Missouri
Tennessee and others they're really
really really uh leaning into making
sure that women people of color and
marginalized communities are having
their Liberty stripped away from them
Texas Paul tell us about your YouTube
channel I watch the latest version of
Sunday coffee yesterday it was a great
it was a great episode everyone go check
it out but tell us about your YouTube
channel over there
oh yeah I've been doing a son I got so
sick and tired of the damn Sunday shows
they're such [ __ ] I mean you know
last Sunday nothing but the queen I mean
people I'm not disrespecting the queen
she was a monarch of one of our greatest
allies
I understand they got a thing going on
right now but you know how many people
here care about that
nobody
no you heard the silence on the mic yeah
that's all you know and every Sunday is
like that so I said screw it I'm doing a
Sunday show where I talk about important
things and last week was Jackson
Mississippi and and the way uh their
Water Crisis and the transgender issue
and trying to get people to understand
that it's actual you know it's not a
mental thing people aren't having a
mental issue to be transgender it's
literally physical they're a physically
different person and we need to treat it
that way that that's who they are not
they're making a choice
um just one thing after another after
another that you see on these Sunday
shows is such crap so
you know I always tell people I'm a
merchant when they say what are you what
do you do for a living to say I'm a
merchant and they're like oh what do you
sell I said
hard truths
you know that's that's what I do that's
what I do and that's what my Sunday show
is going to be you can catch it just do
a search for old Texas Paul and you you
will find me on YouTube
we've got the link here in the chat and
then we also put it down below I put it
down below in the description
um so after the show here make sure you
go check out the link below and follow
Texas Paul at Texas Paul 890 on all the
socials out there in Texas Paul I'm I'm
happy to have you Tuesdays I love it I'm
sorry you had some technical
difficulties but we worked through it
that's what we do here online
there was a stream yard this year turns
out I was fiddling around with stream
yard earlier this week and actually
stream Roger was trying to run a
simulcast of me uh you know I use OBS
and and stream yard so they were
competing for my Computer Resources
I just shut it shut it down you mind if
I throw one more thing out there about
that later yeah because it was really
amazing you know how I I talk about I I
was talking about how we're not that
different
it's not that we Democrats aren't
left because we are it's when you start
talking to Republicans issue to issue
not labels but actual how do we handle
this problem
like that lady was there because of Roe
that's what opened the gate for her
but if you talk to her about health care
well she's with us yeah folks should
have health care but in her mind she's
she's got this talking point where
people should pay for it and if you
explain to people yeah well they do pay
for it you know either through their
labor or you know through their taxes or
whatnot but you go issue to issued issue
guns guns we're really not that far
apart on guns Democrats believe you
should be able to own your guns and not
be an idiot with it
you should be responsible Republicans
believe the same thing
if you get them out of their bubble if
you get them out of their vacuum
we are so close together on these issues
if we can just defeat that right-wing
[ __ ] machine
you know doing what you do Tony I ca I
am not kissing your ass and I say it
every day I'm weak what you and Gabe do
here is amazing y'all run an incredible
podcast because you just tell people the
way it is
and and and that's what was so amazing
to me spending time with this really
nice lady I met her son he's wonderful
wonderful kid you know and and
just talking to her issue the issue she
really became aware that that Democratic
big tent is where she belongs
right well we're going to make it happen
I think I think so uh and and we gotta
lean into democracy as we always say
here uh Texas Paul we we always work
through the technical difficulties no
problem it is Tuesday
um it's Taco Tuesday but it's Texas Paul
Tuesday everyone go subscribe to Texas
Paul's YouTube channel watch him on
Sundays Sunday coffee with Texas fall so
check him out on the Midas touch network
uh you can see a lot of his videos there
and at Paul
tx890 on the socials you can check him
out here we'll we'll cut some of this
interview we'll cut some of the
technical difficulties on it we'll post
it on our YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe here as well Texas
ball thanks for joining us buddy as
always on Tuesdays uh everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part and blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
wowie wowie Wowie
we're at the bottom of the second hour
Gabe we're gonna have to do like
fast round shitless
you gotta surf the Tweety tweets we only
got a few waves left here in the last
half hour
holy actual [ __ ] how is this even how is
this even about no we also have a video
to play too and yeah well um do you have
that loaded up or whatever and that's a
what was what was that right so that is
a what what what what was that what was
that I I'm on I'm all mixed around here
in here let me get the let me get back
to normal here
wowie wowie wow we were having some
technical difficulties with Paul but now
we're in good shape
I saw a comment earlier yeah what was it
I wanted a highlight oh and it was a
good label for the day oh and a lot of
comments a lot of comments loving uh we
love to read the comments
um
[Music]
wow there we go you find it it's
technical troubles Tuesday
technical troubles Tuesday yeah good
night Triple T well and see I mean we
even have technical difficult to see
here so
oh boy oh boy technical issues today
here on the Tony Michaels podcast let's
go ahead that spells something else Tony
what you said technical issues Tuesday
that spells something else technical
issue Tuesdays oh you want yeah you want
it yeah the tit okay all right
all right tit tat
[Laughter]
um
technical issued Tuesday syndrome maybe
that's what we should do oh yeah tits I
don't know I'm just saying I'm just
saying I'm gonna have to reload this hey
everyone this is ridiculous wow
ridiculous we we got what we're doing
over there we got the tits today the
technical issue Tuesday syndrome
um here is here's the newest version of
what what what was that let's go ahead
and let's let's play what was that hey
everyone and welcome to what was that
with Gabe Sanchez and what might be the
most bizarre and deranged Trump rally
I've ever seen Donald Trump complained
about the 2020 election accused John
fetterman of doing drugs and claimed to
have met with Mark Zuckerberg at the
White House last week
I watched Donald Trump's two-hour speech
so you don't have to and here are some
of the more
memorable moments also here's a photo I
took of Republicans who were at the
Trump rally so right out of the gate the
wannabe dictator who ran on a platform
of hate and xenophobia for four years
called President Biden sold the nation's
speech vicious hateful and divisive Joe
Biden came to Philadelphia Pennsylvania
to give
the most vicious hateful and divisive
speech
ever delivered by an American president
I can think of countless vicious hateful
and divisive speeches that Trump gave
while he was President not to mention
Trump's presidential campaign
announcement back in 2015. when Mexico
sends his people they're not sending
their best they're bringing drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
and look if you're offended by Biden
calling out macro Republicans for their
harmful rhetoric and fascist policies
you're part of the problem now before I
get ahead of myself let's see what else
Trump had to say vilifying 75 million
citizens plus another probably 75 to
150. okay 75 million people plus another
75 to 150 million people
[Music]
wait that Math Makes zero sense you know
what maybe I just misunderstood the
speech and Trump is actually United in
the nation he's An Enemy of the State
nope never mind Trump has the audacity
of saying that Biden is an Enemy of the
State when it's Trump that's currently
being investigated for violating the
Espionage I mean nothing screams Enemy
of the State more than treason but you
gotta hand it to Trump in the Republican
party they are professionals when it
comes to projection and hypocrisy
whether it's the economy being sexual
predators or promoting fascism
Republicans will blame others for the
very thing that they are guilty of just
look at Trump back in 2020 when he
called Democrats fascists destroy our
Second Amendment attack the right to
life and replace American Freedom with
left-wing fast
fascists they are fascists and because
Trump didn't have any legitimate
rebuttal to what President Biden said
about McAdory speech Trump could only
comment on the red lighting that was
behind President Biden how do you like
the red lighting behind him like the
devil I'm sorry but this is ridiculous
the guy is literally wearing a red tie
in front of a crowd wearing red Maga
gear and they're waving red signs not to
mention the donation platform used by
Trump and Republicans to Griff money
from their cult is called win red so by
Republican logic their very own donation
platform and the money they receive is
associated with the devil now because
this was the first Trump rally since the
FBI searched Trump's mar-a-laga home he
had to bring it up they rifled through
the first lady's closet drawers and
everything else and even did a deep and
ugly search of the room of my 16 year
old son and the only reason that Trump
mentioned Melania Baron is one for
sympathy and two because he's probably
freaking out that the FBI found whatever
he hid in their stuff also I don't know
of any law enforcement agency that'll
neatly fold your clothes and clean your
home after executing a search warrant
but hey if I'm wrong then I happily
invite the FBI to search my home yet
they go in and take documents dump them
on the floor stage a photo shoot and
pretend that I had done it like I had
put them all over the floor keep in mind
Trump went from accusing the FBI of
planting evidence to then admitting he
took the classified documents to now
accusing the FBI of staging a photo
shoot to make him look like a slob trust
me Trump does not need the FBI's help
with that I mean just look at how he's
kept his other offices and despite Trump
and Republicans complaining about how
the FBI photographed the classified
documents they never complained when
money drugs or weapons are seasoned
photographed by long enforcement you
know typical protocol at a crime scene
actually you know what I think I may
have an easy fix of this whole problem
and it's a bit controversial so just
hear me out if you don't want the FBI to
search your home then don't break the
[ __ ] law I mean honestly guys it's
that simple and of course because the
FBI was mentioned Maga did a good
old-fashioned Locker up chance
[Applause]
and it wouldn't be a trump rally without
Trump whining about how the 2020
election was rigged the 2020 election
was rigged and stolen and now our
country is being destroyed by people who
got into office through cheating and
through fraud look I am not going to
waste my time discussing this ridiculous
issue because it's already been
disproven countless times so let me be
clear to any macro Republicans out there
it wasn't rigged Trump lost and speaking
of the 2020 election Trump just had to
bring up the infamous and perfect phone
call he had with Georgia Secretary of
State Brad raffensberger but the
district attorney Trump made a phone
call because he was challenging
the election
so they're after me for a perfect by the
way perfect phone call you'd be very
proud of me and once again Trump is
openly bragging about how he tried to
influence the 2020 election that he was
running in that's like an athlete going
to a rep during a championship game and
saying hey I need you to add a few
points to my team so we can win so far
throughout the rally I've been able to
understand most of the [ __ ] that
Trump has spewed except for this we will
never let that happen and we will never
let it happen even though we're going to
be gone we're going to set this country
up so strong and so powerfully that we
may not be here at least some of the
older ones that I love you all but we're
going to have the country set up
properly like it was before the covet
came in before the China dust came in
and also this if you want to see
a dead bird Cemetery go under a windmill
sometime it's not a pretty sight if
you're confused by what Trump is talking
about don't worry you're not alone I
mean even I had to call my friend John
Walsh who's a trump impressionist to
help Transit what Trump said what I was
trying to say is the windmills they blew
in the China dust essentially killing
all the little birdies and eventually
we're all gonna die
I don't know I just made that [ __ ] up
anyway moving on according to Trump Mark
Zuckerberg came to see him at the White
House last week last week
weirdo he's a weirdo Mark Zuckerberg
came to the White House kissed my ass
sure I'd love to have dinner
sir I'd love to have dinner I'd love to
bring my lovely wife
all right Mark Come On In
sir you're number one on Facebook I'd
like to congratulate yo thank you very
much Mark I appreciate it I find the
story really hard to believe you know
since Trump was kicked out of the White
House over 18 months ago oh and by the
way Trump is still banned on Facebook
and as if this speech couldn't get any
more bizarre here's one of the crazy
things that Trump said about John
fetterman fetterman supports
taxpayer-funded drug dens and the
complete decriminalization of illegal
drugs including heroin cocaine crystal
meth and Ultra lethal Fentanyl and by
the way he takes them himself I'm sorry
what was that Fentanyl and by the way he
takes them himself Trump publicly
accusing John Federman of being a drug
addict with no proof is straight from
the Maga Playbook and this is just one
example amongst many from Trump's speech
that was vicious hateful and divisive
and that's the theme at every Trump
rally if you go against Trump and Magus
fascist beliefs then you are an Enemy of
the State and as much as Donald Trump
wants to be a dictator he's nothing more
than a broke impotent narcissistic
simple-minded weakness an insecure man
baby and I can't wait till that Trader's
in prison well I'm Gabe Sanchez and this
has been what was that
[Music]
oh what was that what was that that
great episode on the truck I don't know
on the Trump rally that uh that was that
was a great one then you're not gonna
follow him around the country and do
more of these are you no no no no no for
my own sanity I can only watch so far I
guess so I got you well that makes sense
that makes sense we got a lot of stuff
to round up but we've only got 20
minutes so let's get right into it let's
go to the shitless Roundup where we
round up the Tweety tweets and journey
Trends I got some video to show you
let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's do a fast Round Here is uh Al
Franken on CNN yeah another what was
that that's coming up actually on this
this is this is crazy this has been
going around we actually tried to pull
this video I don't know if something's
wrong with CNN's feed or something it
was hard to find a decent video
um I I think the Deep state was trying
to shut up Al Franken here because he
was saying he was saying the truth way
out loud when I'm saying what's
happening yes when he's saying what is
gonna happen because I think I think
this is why people are so engaged is
because it is clear now more than ever
that they are not only willing to let
people lose their rights it is their
goal listen
the legitimacy of the Court was
undermined when they wouldn't take up
Merrick Garland and you'll remember that
McConnell said it was because it was
during election year and you remember
Lindsey Graham pledging that if a
vacancy came uh came open during
election year in uh 20 that he wouldn't
vote for
um they wouldn't they wouldn't take up a
nominee they've stolen two seats the one
that Merrick Garland
uh wasn't given a hearing for
and the one that Coney Barrett was uh
where she was seated a week before the
election
that destroyed the legitimacy of the
Court
Alice what do you think did Chief
Justice Roberts sort of I mean he sort
of uh ignored some of what Al is talking
about there and that there is I mean a
tremendous amount of controversy but uh
as to how this court got tilted in the
direction of the far right just to throw
a little accuracy and some of what what
Al said there look the the Merrick
Garland
was held up because we had a divided
government we had a democrat in the
white house and we had Republicans in
control of that's not what was that
that's not what McConnell said but but
that's the way historically this has
been when you're in close to an election
year and you have divided government
yeah historically not yes and when you
have divided government there typically
is a inclination to tell me what has
happened before when you tell me when
you're well Merit Garland government
they're they're moving they're not
moving forward tell me what has happened
before Al I'm telling you this is what
tell me what had happened before I can't
believe it happened historically tell me
when it happened before look this is the
way that the Republicans
like I can't give you an exact example
of when this happened
because it hadn't happened before
oh my God Al Franken look
I'm not saying Al Franken should or
shouldn't be a center but he definitely
should be a senator again yeah something
somewhere he should be sitting in a
chair questioning these [ __ ] he
used to do this in the Senate and these
committee hearings yeah he used to do it
so well like he would dissect these
people now here he's a little more
um less you know what do you want to
call it uh diplomatic I guess about his
questioning well I think
yeah exactly I mean like you know
obviously we've seen far worse from
Representatives on the Republican side
you know or Senators but
in this moment you know he's a private
citizen he's just there speaking his
mind and in this moment no [ __ ] yeah no
[ __ ] give he's like when did they say
it when did they say it legit she's like
oh well I yeah look I is it almost
sounded like we were having a bad
connection on the phone with someone
right like that's how much she was doing
and breaking up her speech like uh this
well it because she was challenged and
here's the thing at the end of the day
this is what we need to do too many
times we've seen some person on the
right come on and spew some [ __ ]
misinformation lies and they just accept
it and they go okay next question and
they do not challenge it right whether
it was Jake Tapper talking to uh you
know Bolton about planning coups in
other countries or whatever it might be
this is something they don't do and
especially you don't see it with guests
on the other side where they basically
take over the debate and say uh prove it
show me the receipts show me the
receipts fine I'll show you I will tell
you right now Mitch McConnell said this
Lindsey Graham said this they did this
they want to guess what they promised
and even in this clip there's it's about
10 minutes really in length and they go
he goes into specifics talking about how
the people that got those stolen seats
promised
that they would not overturn Roe v Wade
and Casey and Parenthood like all these
things were law of the land and that
is is the truth of it is you know you
got to challenge these people in real
time and you gotta fact check them so
that they aren't able to get across
their whole point because this is what's
going to happen you challenge them they
will stumble and they will fall and you
will win this and you gotta lean into
that [ __ ] absolutely lean in uh
speaking of scumbags on TV
um you said you gotta get out these
scumbags here let's get it Tucker
Carlson here because he says something
this was last I think this was last
Friday this was Friday he's he has
someone on his TV who's a lawyer who's a
who's a lawyer for all these
insurrectionists and all these Trump
allies these traitors and um they said
he reported on the show that up to 50
Trump
um supporters had been rated is the word
that they used of course they weren't
raided
um they were issued subpoenas and and
their cell phones were seized by the
federal authorities but listen to this
report and then I'm going to show you
another report that shows you the real
story because it's the grand jury today
story we don't know the full parameters
of it but apparently the FBI has
launched a full-scale purge of
supporters of Donald Trump that would be
Joe Biden's likely opponent in the
coming presidential no it's not there's
the election now that's not the election
then he can go [ __ ] off and the other
thing I want to say about what this this
piece of [ __ ] is saying here is is the
uh um Trump supporters he's making it
sound like it's people sitting in their
chairs at home watching Tucker Carlson
jerking off with Cheetos in their hand
no that is not what it this is it is
people who were close to Trump who were
trying to overthrow our government and
grifting you sitting in the chair
jerking off to your Cheetos into Tucker
Carlson okay that is that is who they
stole they stole your [ __ ] money and
they're stealing your brain power
they're stealing your [ __ ] time and
they're stealing your energy
let's continue election and that Purge
has intensified significantly today so
Steve Bannon just heard that yesterday
okay okay he says Steve Bannon just said
never in the history of any kind of real
news journalism has someone been like
you know what the truth is what Steve
Bannon said yeah if I if I were to grow
if I were to quote the great philosopher
and uh and teacher Steve Bannon right
the walking scab yeah Steve Bannon Jesus
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me let's continue
whoa the FBI raid the homes of dozens of
trump allies
we want to get to the bottom of this
story so that I'm Charlie Kirk show
today we can try to run it down ever
since we reached oh there it is again
Charlie can we said that today on
Charlie Kirk's show I mean it just you
know all these songs
right wing everyone's got their right
hand jerking off another [ __ ] dick
that is in the Republican party right
well if they're if they're you know no
one can use their left hand right one
you gotta have one hand for the Cheeto
dust right right you gotta feed the
Cheeto dust that keeps you having the
energy for the circle jerk apparently
let's listen to what I'm sure this
attorney it's on Fox News it's on Tucker
Carlson oh yeah I'm sure oh man I'm sure
this is gonna be just you know we have
Christina Bob out there yapping her trap
now she's getting an attorney she has to
because she's a traitor uh we have uh
Haba you have trusty I'm sure this one's
way different than that yeah yeah sure
so that's a Harmony Dylan who says she's
got some information on this she's
managing partner in the Dylan Law Group
hermit thanks so much for coming on
what is the truth
[Applause]
this is a great question I'm not even
going to play I'm not even gonna play
after that day what is the truth and I
think you know Republicans as much as
they uh search for that truth right is
that that thing that they're they're
always looking for because they never
tell uh they never believe in the actual
truth
um that is what it what is the truth
well to Republicans the truth is
whatever they want to believe it's
whatever confirmation bias they need to
believe in some crazy conspiracy about
covid the election Donald Trump stealing
classified documents whatever it be
their truth is the opposite of what the
actual truth is right well and and so
now we find out yesterday late yesterday
I think it was in the afternoon late in
the afternoon yesterday that yes in fact
in fact there were people close to Trump
who have received subpoenas for a grand
jury a criminal grand jury and had their
phones seized that is the actual news
that's the the truth of it not this
whiny little [ __ ] thing oh they stole
my phone no you committed crime is what
you did and now they're finding out
you [ __ ] around now they're finding
out and you're gonna find out and that's
just the thing this is not this is not
coincidental after John Eastman's phone
Jeffrey Clarkson we have Pat cipolloni
testifying before a grand jury we have
other Trump officials testifying before
a grand jury in Washington DC around the
January 6th now more and more and more
it's being found out about this legal
defense fund as the January 6 select
committee uh briefs the doj with the
information that they collected from
their investigation into January 6 and
where that money went this man and and
to think that this is not all tied
together the Trump Oregon and York the
the case in Georgia where they're trying
to overthrow the election the [ __ ] in
Florida where he stole all these [ __ ]
documents that absolutely have to do
with him right like the documents are
about him about crimes he committed uh
or it's about blackmail or or what he
can sell that's what it's about and it's
all interconnected every single bit of
it is interconnected to one [ __ ]
one one [ __ ] that's why it is so
hard to stop talking about this stupid
son of a [ __ ] it's because it's one
[ __ ] that it always goes back to
and that's Donald Trump but let's listen
to the breaking news here yesterday as
it broke on MSNBC because I think they
actually broke the news yeah Pete
this is something that has probably been
churning under the surface but I wonder
if it is a sign that it is more advanced
that so much of it is now poking out
above the surface
well Nicole I think absolutely it is and
what's important to remember is this was
not the Department of Justice announcing
the subpoenas in these search forms
these are largely information that is
coming to I believe the New York Times
by the people who receive the subpoenas
the people who received the search
warrants or their attorneys so it may
well be this group is even larger than
the 40 that the New York Times is
reporting on but this is exactly the
sort of thing as an investigator and
certainly you know working with
prosecutors you know there are events in
the course of your investigation that
are going to likely become public so it
doesn't surprise me that the Department
of Justice was looking as they conducted
their investigation as that
investigation progressed closer and
closer to former president Trump that
they decided okay at some date certain
we are going to go out we are going to
issue a lot of these because of the
likelihood that knowledge will become
public and that you saw a burst of
activity like you uh that you're seeing
in this reporting make no mistake about
it 40 subpoenas is a lot of subpoenas
multiple search warrants for cell phones
is at an even higher standard of
evidentiary proof that's required to
obtain that warrant these are
significant investigative steps and the
fact that they're people who are in
direct contact with a former president
really speaks to the gravity and the
advanced nature of this investigation
so there you have it um of course of
course they they found out because these
people are whining and complaining one
of them is Stephen Miller one of them is
Stephen Miller I think we didn't we have
a clip of Stephen Miller um we posted a
clip last night about him yes there was
a clip of Stephen Miller that we posted
last night I believe he was on um uh one
of these Trader news networks oh the
king of Trader news networks Fox News so
let's let me see if I can grab that clip
there and if I can find it what was she
was he on lore Ingram yeah he was on
Lauren okay here we go
um so here he was this is one of the the
uh subjects of the of the search warrant
and The subpoena let's listen in the
last week the justice department has
issued 40 subpoenas seats two phones of
trump Associates over January 6. your
response to this uh less than two months
before a midterm election will come
after your flight that's that's the
point though isn't it I mean of course
it's already been well it's been
publicly reported that I was on the list
of of subpoenas in the New York Times
but that's the point right when are they
due so did they take his phone or his
mommy's phone well they he they took his
both his parents phone him well I guess
all three right him his mother and his
father because remember right the excuse
the excuse that Stephen Miller gave was
you can't take my phone because I am
still on my parents plan I
it makes no it makes no sense because
here's the thing well no in legal Court
you can make the argument that the
reason why you can't convict me a crime
of stuff I did on this phone is because
it's not really mine I don't actually
right right right now you know God
forbid that uh I don't know a phone
carrier is able to say oh look it's on
this number yeah we don't need to give
you the other number right we just give
you the one number that's in question I
mean if you have reasonable doubt that
you need to look at these numbers sure
good I mean we won't we won't we won't
uh try to fight you on this do you think
if mommy went and bought him another
phone now that he's got I don't know I
mean that's a that's a that's a I mean
the iPhone 14 is coming out soon so who
knows maybe they said it's the exact
same thing though right never ever that
that it's all [ __ ] that there's
nothing new about the 14 they're just oh
yeah well there's a there's a couple
things that are actually different oh
okay well maybe Steven Miller will get
lucky in his mouth good little fascist
and his mom might
I mean this guy is pure evil and he is
unwilling to in the reason he is
unwilling to admit he will not admit to
Laura Ingraham right now on the show if
the phone was actually taken away it's
because if he does then it will prove
that there was uh there was reason to
suspect that he was involved in whatever
the crimes that he's being you know
looked at for right well the reason why
reason why they would take a [ __ ]
phone like that and they would have a
probe that direct towards a specific
phone here's the reason why is because
they have back-end other phones that
show the [ __ ] crime right they want
to see who the [ __ ] he was talking to
right because there's communication
inside text message threads to another
person on another phone right where he
says this person says this in other
words they're trying to track down
they're trying to track down the chain
of communication it's what they're doing
they're trying to figure out who the
[ __ ] is the point of communication who's
giving the orders where and that's why
they're seizing all these [ __ ] phones
Clark uh they took didn't they take
another one of Clarks I believe they
yeah yeah I can't remember they're so I
mean well every time every time because
the other thing too is like if if it's
not on tape then these people who get
their phones taken away or their
property taken away c's for a search
warrant or subpoena uh they can cause
they can cast doubt right because he
says well that's what the New York Times
was reporting but even in the other
video Peter reveals that like the reason
that we know about these things is not
because these people at the doj or the
FBI saying hey hey Carlson yeah
they are admitting this and telling them
that oh hey just so you know they are
persecuting us Tony they are [ __ ]
persecuting us for being an American
citizen who believes in the life liberty
in the pursuit of happiness oh yeah so
what we try to Stage a coup or what we
tried to overthrow the government or
what we tried to you know uh cause an
election to be you know know invalid
these are the people or you know further
or more crimes worse crimes whatever
they may be this is the group that will
whine and complain oh no I'm being
persecuted I'm being I'm being my my my
my my own rights are being taken away
from me yeah because you [ __ ] broke
the law or you did something that were
you attempted to do something to break a
law and here's the thing
you are the one who is openly admitting
we don't have some leak coming out of
the doj saying hey just so you know we
took away this person's phone and this
ways person's phone and this way the
only reason we're finding out about this
if it's released in court documents that
are open to the public or the person who
is the owner of that device is revealing
to a new station hey they [ __ ] took
my stuff that is so [ __ ] and that's
important because here's why is because
and this is why this is going to be so
beautiful in the end of this I'm telling
you folks I know it's going to take a
while but it is going to come all
crashing down on them because they're
using the flood the Zone tactic like
they used for grab them by the [ __ ]
video like they used for the
Charlottesville both sides thing they're
using the flood to Zone tactic with a
bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch of lies
and they're just trying to get out there
to get as much meaning as possible but
it doesn't matter it's the [ __ ]
Department of Justice it's the FBI
they've got all the time and all the
resources in the world for the [ __ ]
find out stage and you've reached it
Stephen Miller let's finish doing this
right before the midterms what is this
all about what has it always been about
we've had this conversation on your show
many times it's about using the power of
the justice department to influence our
elections it's about the partisanship
that has infected the doj at the highest
levels that everyone who Treasures the
rule of law in America should be
terrified
they did not do this before and I told
you last night I was that they did not
do this they did not cause this before
the midterms Trump did he delayed for
almost two years didn't want to give the
documents and then when the FBI and the
doj was like this is [ __ ] too far we
have to come get this [ __ ] it's because
Trump delayed look
it's not their fault it is Trump's fault
if he would have not taken the documents
or returned the documents and be like
oops sorry it got packed on them got
packed up in the boxes and went on the
U-Haul trucks sorry about that here you
go this would not even be an issue and
it would not be a problem for
Republicans to try to weave their way
around and say oh this is no this isn't
a big guys this isn't a big deal he
didn't do anything wrong it's their
fault Chris Trump was the one you're on
Facebook she says he needs a pardon
blanket
[Music]
oh my God oh my God you know what I hope
they're right I hope this is all dark
Brandon and he's coming after him for
with a political Vendetta and he's gonna
put them all in prison nothing would
make me happy or speaking of dark
Brandon when I go to store.the
tonymichaels.com
custom the Tony Michaels podcast
designer you can't get it anywhere else
besides
store.dtonymichaels.com shirts hoodies
mugs stickers get your dark Brandon
merch today again go to
store.theytonymichaels.com it's also
down in the link description below
game damn it just this two hours flew
with Texas Paul it always does by quick
and we we didn't get to everything I
wanted to get to luckily we're on every
single weekday so don't worry we'll get
to it tomorrow in one of them now I do
have to say
I'm gonna blame it on you here I mean
yeah okay you can write a bonehead of
the week is a little a little Askew
because Gabe Gabe's got to build another
bunker or some [ __ ] so he'll be
unavailable on Friday so here's what
George Soros is making me come to the
bunker and I have to plan how to
overthrow an election right right so
I'll be unavailable Thursday and Friday
okay so here's what we're gonna do so
Thursday Gabe will not be on here Friday
he will be because we're gonna do bone
end of the week like we do every Friday
but today you're gonna vote you're gonna
vote today or bone end of the week me
and Gabe are gonna secretly you won't
know it even though I'm telling you now
we're gonna record it tomorrow once you
vote and then we will Air it like we do
every single Friday right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast in the second hour
so make sure to go follow us on Twitter
at the Tony Michael at Tony Michaels pod
it's important because you'll be able to
vote there also subscribe here on
YouTube because you will be able to vote
here on YouTube as well don't miss the
poll will be today so everyone out there
Bonet of the week you gotta vote today
there's early registration for the bone
end of the week and it's [ __ ] today
folks so we will we will we will keep
our regular schedule it'll just be so
Gabe will be here on Friday he just I
will be actually be here but I'll I'll
be here but I won't be here right yeah
and that you can thank for George Soros
that's true that's true it's all it's
all the Deep State speaking of the deep
State don't forget to download every
deep State podcast here the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify Google
leave us a great deep State review over
there on your favorite directory as you
subscribe to the podcast
Gabe it's been a quick two hours here
but don't worry tomorrow same time same
place noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting over on the books of face
everyone have a safe afternoon a safe
evening we'll see you tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon